jennifer lopez is standing by ben
affleck's side as he clears up those
controversial comments he made about his
marriage to jennifer garner and even
being the subject of that is just sort
of the cost of doing business a little
bit as an actor but like not with my
kids don't do that it's wrong it hurts
me and your family
it all started earlier this week when
the last dual star appeared on
siriusxm's the howard stern show and
opened up about his past relationship
with garner and how alcoholism affected
his marriage and during a stop by jimmy
kimmel live on wednesday after receiving
some backlash on social media for his
comments the 49 year old oscar winner
explained how his remarks were twisted
by the media i'd gone on and said like
how much we respect each other and cared
about each other and cared about our
kids and put them first and went through
our stuff and he said that i had blamed
my ex-wife from my alcoholism and that i
was trapped in this marriage like just
made me out to be like the worst most
insensitive stupid awful guy affleck
went on saying that while he doesn't
mind being turned into a meme from time
to time when it comes to his family he
draws the line of course
like that's not true i don't believe
that it's the exact opposite of who i am
what i believe and i would never
want my kids to think i would ever say a
bad word about their mom because this
really upset you i mean obviously
of course this all comes after affleck
sat down with stern and recalled the
circumstances that led to his divorce
from garner whom he shares three
children with sixteen-year-old violet
twelve-year-old seraphina and
nine-year-old samuel we grew apart we
had a marriage that didn't work this
happens it's somebody i love and respect
but
to whom i was i shouldn't be married any
longer and we said you know what we
don't want ultimately we tried we tried
we tried because we had kids
and then we said we don't both of us
felt like we don't want this to be the
model that our kids see of marriage
affleck went on to say the split was
amicable adding that if they had not
ended their relationship they would have
quote ended up at each other's throats
and he quote would probably still be
drinking and on wednesday following the
backlash from his interview his current
girlfriend jennifer lopez was right by
his side walking hand-in-hand with him
as he arrived at jimmy kimmel live's los
angeles studio during his sit down with
stern ben also opened up about his
rekindled relationship with the singer
admitting that negative media attention
during their first relationship was
partially responsible for their 2004
split i would say it was about 50
percent
like the idea that
people hate you
and they hate you together and that
being together is poison and ugly and
toxic and thing none of us want to be
part of and who would want to have them
to dinner what the [ __ ] are they doing
together and when et spoke with lopez in
2014 she expressed a similar sentiment
it was my first like adult heartbreak
was it because it was so public and we
wanted to know every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help we were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak fast forward to 2021 and the
two are very much back on and while the
oscar winner has played coy about his
relationship i don't know if you are
aware of how good the internet thinks
you look it's like all everyone's
talking about lately i think you might
be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that when she you're big on the quarter
because i wasn't sure about where they
told me it's fall earlier this week
lopez was there to support her man at
the premiere of his new film tender bar
and affleck he said when it comes to the
media he just wants to keep it
professional in my life
i've been through a lot of different
kinds of experiences with the press and
it's just a it's like a function of what
you do right it's not my favorite part
of the job it's not what i would choose
to do but it is a responsibility in mind
i take seriously
[Music]
you